[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa tarde
agora sim chegou o cara da tecnologia
vamos falar e de conectividade à
internet das coisas blot em realidade
virtual big deitar analytics carro
autônomo no perdão pessoal
hoje eu vou decepcionar todos vocês
tecnologias podem buscar na internet
busca à vontade lá eles vão aprender
bastante
hoje eu vim aqui pra ser sincero com
vocês para falar de gente eu sou sim
entusiasta um apaixonado pela tecnologia
mas sou infinitamente mais apaixonado
pelo ser humano por pessoas e aí sim
pela em pelo impacto que a tecnologia
pode causar na qualidade de vida das
pessoas e do ser humano
ela nem sou tão bom assim tecnologia lá
em casa vou ser sincero
a grande tecnologia da casa minha esposa
porque quando ela que instala tudo ela
conecta tudo a loja de aplicativos a
instalar na tv ela está nas coisas
crianças e quando dá pau em alguma coisa
amorim pessoa não está conectado aqui na
f1mania aqui falou eu não sei fazer isso
macul sangue
como você pode ser presidente lembra
tecnologia será refinada e tecnologia
falou eu não preciso entender muito de
tecnologia eu só preciso entender um
pouco de gente ea minha paixão por isso
por gente por pessoas que são elas que
me ajudaram a chegar aonde eu cheguei
hoje aqui e é um prazer que eu tenho de
poder tá falando um pouco pra vocês da
minha história como eu cheguei aqui
então aqui está um começo de todas as
coisas
eu nasci 5 estava falando colega aqui
uma pequena cidade no sul do mato grosso
do sul chamada batayporã com y
extremamente que anota aí é eu nasci na
verdade debaixo da das tábuas essa
casinha que vocês estão vendo aí nasce
pelas mãos de uma parteira em 1970
meus pais que nunca você for para a
escola o suficiente para aprender a ler
e escrever e são os meus verdadeiros
heróis
porque com eles eu aprendi e sabedoria
não tem nada a ver com a qualidade da
instituição de ensino você faz no brasil
ou no mundo mas tem a ver com aquilo que
se aprende na faculdade da vida e foi
tudo que aprendi de verdade com eles e
se eu cheguei eu cheguei onde cheguei
hoje saindo de lá podendo passar por
escolas municipais estaduais e poder
chegar onde eu cheguei pode ter certeza
que não é porque eu sou bom mas porque
eu fui oportunizado eu tive oportunidade
eu sou um velho ser um exemplo de tantos
que existem de um filho dá a
oportunidade desse país e quantos outros
talentos espalhados pelo redor do nosso
país inteiro se tiver uma oportunidade
vai fazer de tudo para poder vencer e
fazer aquela oportunidade de ser uma
realidade
por isso que eu sou um apaixonado de
ajudar que leve sim através da
tecnologia a oportunidade ea educação a
todos porque isso equivale e só chega em
algum lugar através das pessoas pessoas
se dão as oportunidades pessoas te dão
ensino pessoas se dão aconselhamento
pessoas se ajudam pessoas que abrem as
portas
por isso essa minha paixão que eu sempre
tive de verdade no coração por pessoas
por ser humano
tive uma trajetória talvez não tão
diferente do que tantos outros fiz um
pouco de tudo sim meu pai doente e
quando somos quatro irmãos quando tinha
três anos de idade ele veio pra cá são
paulo foi para são paulo para poder dar
uma vida melhor para os filhos conseguiu
nunca conquistou nada pra ele não
conquistou tudo com os filhos
principalmente a educação vendia no
boteco um pão e leite de manhã e vendia
pinho à noite e assim sustentou os
filhos ele minha mãezinha né eu
trabalhei a gente ajudava a ele no atrás
do balcão até contive 12 anos de idade
eu pude ser trilhado esse pegador de
bolinhas de tênis no clube banespa em
são paulo fiz isso com muito orgulho por
dois anos sabe domingo 4 horas da manhã
acordado ônibus lotado vão poder chegar
para poder fazer
não porque vai ajudar em casa mas tudo
que podia ter dinheiro para se ajudar
já ajudava muito é isso foi crescendo
durante 12 anos de idade tá fazendo isso
com 14 anos de idade conseguiu o
primeiro emprego de office boy
aquilo foi um privilégio
gera um banco e poder chegar em casa pai
mãe conseguiu emprego vou ganhar 167 mil
cruzeiros ou seja ela qual o dia da
época e que orgulho poder falar aquilo
então trabalhos em 10 dos 14 anos aos 16
anos de idade eu tive aí talvez o que eu
gostaria de deixar um exemplo aqui uma o
primeiro grande choque na europa fazendo
já o colégio técnico e eu queria tive
uma oportunidade de tirar uma carteira
registrada com o futebol e queria poder
ser um tinha uma oportunidade de
estagiar numa empresa para trabalhar já
com computação e aquilo entusiasmo mas
você não tinha mais carteira registrada
estava com a carteira registrada se você
perdesse o interesse em continuar no
emprego se eu podia ser um escriturário
auxiliar de escritório seguir a carreira
no banco mas poxa eu queria trabalhar
com computação já tinha feito até um
curso de datilografia você gosta e sabe
o que é isso na vida mas é meu pai pagou
aí ele chegou eu falei pai é eu tô com
uma oportunidade aqui vou eu não sei que
eu faço pai porque olha eu tô aqui no
banco estou feliz me tratam bem tudo
mais netos usando a noite chega em casa
a mãe já deixou ali todo o arroz ali pra
gente
a gente começou e está tudo bem na vida
estou feliz aqui mas eu queria trabalhar
com o computador e um computador eu
tenho essa oportunidade estagiário não
sei o que fazer porque se não foi
efetivado ou perder tudo
meu pai olhando pra mim assim filho eu
não entendi nada que você está falando
mas seu olho está brilhando filho
então siga o brilho dos seus olhos eu te
prometo que nunca vai faltar nem comida
nem o que vestir siga o seu sonho é
fácil você tem que fazer e aquilo pra
mim imagina o que significou aquele
conselho sábio na minha vida que mudou
tudo que eu fiz a frente e por isso o
meu orgulho tanto da sabedoria que vem
da vida e aquele concelho fui trabalhar
com isso com 16 anos de idade com 18 fui
campeã foi uma indústria manufatura
trabalhando sempre aí sim com tecnologia
foi crescendo até que fui para indústria
mesmo não usuárias de tecnologia como
grandes bancos o manufatura para uma
indústria que fornecia tecnologia
fui crescendo fui do técnico foi
vendedor foi gerente
até que aos 36 anos assumiu a
presidência de uma empresa de software
aqui no brasil
aos 40 anos eu fui podia assumir a
presidência a américa latina da empresa
e hoje estou aqui como como líder
principal do país e uma das maiores
empresas de tecnologia do mundo de novo
porque eu sou bom
não porque eu tive a oportunidade e que
a gente possa com governos e empresas
privadas levar cada vez mais e fomentar
as oportunidades para busca desses
talentos que estão orando todos os dias
por uma oportunidade a cada dia e por
isso o entusiasmo tanto a nesse mundo de
hoje no trabalho com tecnologia como
muda tudo eu até gosto mais de falar do
do qual é o futuro do trabalho do que o
trabalho do futuro né mas não faz muita
diferença ea semântica
mas a verdade é que neste planeta com 50
milhões de devices conectados todo mundo
conectado a tudo ea todos tudo muda
mesmo na nossa forma de trabalhar e
acaba virando uma linha muito tênue
entre quando eu estou trabalhando quando
não estou trabalhando quando eu estou no
trabalho quando estou em casa quando
estou com a família quando estou
cuidando das coisas pessoas que estão
fazendo esporte uma vez que não se está
100% conectado com tudo e com todos
você pode estar fazendo tudo e todos a
qualquer momento e isso muda tudo então
o futuro trabalho no futuro vai pesar
muito mais e tem que pesar na nossa vida
a qualidade de vida o quanto você
consegue fazer o balanço e equilíbrio
pra você ser feliz naquilo que você faz
seja onde você estiver fazendo e como
você estiver fazendo esse é o trabalho
que têm do futuro você hoje em dia você
está preocupado ainda o estresse que
causa na vida do ser humano de falar que
hora que eu vou chegar numa reunião
puxa quando você está preocupado em
chegar cedo cachorro que está
acontecendo você está nervoso desde a
noite anterior
se já dorme mal você acorda mal vocês
produzem não consegue levar direito
filho na escola se não consegue fazer um
monte de coisa porque tem que tá naquela
hora
trabalhando e tentar àquela hora que tem
que chegar chegar atrasado que seu chefe
vai falar tudo isso é uma preocupação
muito grande que pode ser aliviada então
hoje em dia tem que se falar mesmo que
esse mundo conectado sair para o bem
é o tal do enem é office
o escritório está na palma da mão e hoje
eu saio
deixo meus filhos na escola numa boa
quando eu entro trabalho se tem trânsito
e daí eu tô com escritório na palma da
mão então o futuro do trabalho tem tudo
a ver com aquilo que você faz e não mais
aonde você está tão grave isso e isso é
um ponto seja qual é o trabalho em
qualquer indústria qualquer segmentação
de mercado
o futuro do trabalho sobre o que nós
fazemos e não há onde nós estamos
o que a gente tem que tomar e tomar
muito cuidado
é que para essa tecnologia hoje toda que
nos traz tanto benefício que pode trazer
tanta benefício não só para as famílias
como para os cidadãos como para os
trabalhadores
essa tecnologia que pode permitir com
que você tem todo mundo indo até a
educação pode ser difícil não você pode
levar a educação a todos através da
tecnologia você trazer todos atrás até
um ponto de de tratamento médico é muito
difícil mas com a tecnologia você
consegue levar o atendimento médico
através de por exemplo telemedicina aos
cantões do nosso brasil então você
consegue fazer muito com a tecnologia
com a tecnologia nem onde os alunos
oceanos sumiram neto foi encurtando as
fronteiras foram desapareceram
você está a um clique ou a um comando de
voz dos seus entes queridos no mundo
inteiro
amigos parentes filhos mas a ou seja
você está agora como se tivesse aqui do
seu andando você consegue estar em
qualquer lugar a qualquer momento com
qualquer um que você queira por conta da
tecnologia mas por outro lado esse é o
grande cuidado estivesse que guardar
alguma coisa na cabeça que guarde isso
porque a tecnologia que salva é a mesma
que cega não é diferente a tecnologia a
tecnologia é a mesma então aquela
tecnologia que te dá o bem-estar de
estou o conectado com tudo e com todos e
estou feliz é a mesma tecnologia que
quando você chega em casa e que teu
filho te dá um
abraço você não dá porque tem mais uma
mensagem venha para responder só mais
uma mensagem ou da tua fia que quer
contar como foi importante o primeiro
dia de balé dela e você nunca escuta
ainda porque por um pouquinho que eu
tenho só mais uma reunião eu tenho só
vai ver esse lance aqui do facebook eu
tenho só que vê mais isso ou seja ela
cega sem você perceber que é pior porque
ao mesmo tempo que ela te traz um
benefício todo está conectando com quem
você quer ela que traz o não benefício
de estar conectado com todo mundo mesmo
se você não queira então você não ter
você tem um jantar da sua família você
está conectado naquele jantar e com todo
mundo ao redor e você não pode esquecer
não deixa que o foco principal de tudo
que a gente faz na vida é o ser humano
são as pessoas não perca isso de vida
porque nós que você perder sem você
perceber você está cego pela tecnologia
não sendo salvo por ela ea tecnologia
simplesmente a mesma tenha isso sempre
na cabeça
nunca perca aqueles que você ama por
conta da tecnologia
eu tive sim essa carreira uma carreira
uma jornada que foi espetacular na minha
vida uma jornada onde eu pude crescer eu
pude aprender
eu caí muito cair levantar cair levantar
cair levantar a chorar a correr risco de
vida entrar dentro do ônibus colocar o
pé dentro braço com a marmita na na na
mochila ou seja vive muita coisa eu
aprendi muita coisa tive muita alegria
teve muita tristeza chorei demais eu ri
demais mas foi uma jornada brilhante e
tão brilhante nem a ponto de estar a ter
saído da cidade vizinha de batayporã tô
falando hoje aqui um grupo de pessoas
simplesmente espetacular e isso é um
privilégio muito grande que eu agradeço
o cara lá em cima que ter cuidado muito
de mim e das pessoas que me ajudaram a
chegar até aqui
e nesse tempo nessa onde eu fui
aprendendo alguma coisa comigo mesmo foi
estabelecendo eu coloquei aqui uma as
minhas regras de ouro não minhas regras
de ouro porque eu não peguei de nenhum
livro nem nada disso foi a regra de ouro
estabelecendo pra mim não assim vendemos
só eu fui adotando pra mim ao longo do
que eu fui aprendendo justamente com
essa maravilha que está colocando as
pessoas em primeiro lugar é o primeiro
ponto que eu coloco aqui pra vocês então
e seja carreira você estiver
empreendedorismo corporativismo é
trazendo o bem da sociedade ou pra
população não importa o que você esteja
fazendo em primeiro lugar
a primeira regra que eu coloquei na
minha vida eu fiz pra mim
coloque sempre as pessoas em primeiro
lugar mas coloque genuinamente em
primeiro lugar não porque um livro fala
as pessoas não estão preocupadas com
quanto você sabe
elas querem saber o quanto você tá
preocupado com elas mas o ser humano
nasce é o criador acho que fez já um
chip zinho aqui na placa principal onde
o senhor consegue identificar se está
falando com demagogia ou não se você é
sincero mesmo não são seja quando você
tira os olhos de você mesmo e coloca nas
outras pessoas elas fazem mágica por
você
por isso eu digo com convicção que eu só
estou aqui hoje por conta das pessoas e
não porque eu nunca fui o melhor da
escola nunca foi número 1 nunca foi o
melhor aluno nunca foi o obama ou mais
inteligente mas eu sempre fui um
apaixonado por está conectado e com as
pessoas e colocando elas em primeiro
lugar não também porque eu aprendi mas
porque a vida foi me ensinou assim e
talvez meu pai e minha mãe sempre
ensinaram que de atenção simplesmente
para todo mundo não importa que ela seja
quanto dinheiro ela tem na carteira no
bolso e isso vale simplesmente
mais-que-tudo número 2 seja sempre você
mesmo
chore de risada seja vulnerável você vai
errar fala que serrou pede perdão seja
autêntico que você consiga ou se vai ser
muito mais feliz se você não ficar
tentando a vida inteira com todo mundo
tentando ser aquele que você não é
você vai ser feliz sendo autêntico seja
autêntico e eu tenho certeza que você
vai ser feliz primeiro vai fazer as
pessoas felizes
o mundo vai conspirar completamente o
seu favor
comemore sempre cada vitória no mundo
corporativo é uma tristeza muito grande
você tem uma meta enorme para fechar no
final do ano
e você fecha um bom mês você não celebra
que está com medo de não fechar aquele
ano
é só você cada batalha que você vence
puxa vida celebra cada batalha não fica
com medo de gritar ou de celebrar não
celebra fim você fechou 14 ou se você é
tem gente que vai assim não escala e não
têm escala montanhas escala montanhas
casa quando chega lá em cima não espera
ver o pôr do sol já desce não escalá
outra não
poxa conquistou primeira montanha senta
curte aproveita respira a idéia é se vai
enfrentar outra montanha mas não deixa
de celebrar cada vitória cada passo que
você der a sua vida e cada passo que
sejam passos firmes
eu nunca pensei em ser presidente nada
pra falar a verdade
mas eu sempre queria entregar muito bem
o meu trabalho eu sou contratado para
fazer e aí sim entregue sempre algo mais
mas cada passo olhe faça muito bem feito
que você com certeza colocando as
pessoas em primeiro lugar você vai ser
reconhecido e por último aqui nunca
nunca nunca nunca nunca nunca perca sua
família nunca pé é o centro de toda a
felicidade que pode acontecer na sua
vida na sociedade em qualquer lugar do
mundo é a felicidade da sua família
se você perder uma formatura onerosa diz
alguma coisa importante na vida do seu
filho por causa de uma reunião
extremamente importante que vai
acontecer
eu tinha seguro daqui um tempo se não
terminam lembrança do que foi aquela
reunião vai lembrar o resto da vida que
você perdeu um grande evento na vida do
seu filho por conta do mundo corporativo
num capeta sua família
nunca feira eu coloco aqui obrigado eu
coloquei aqui um videozinho já
terminando aqui que foi um negócio que
me marcou muito nos últimos anos que foi
eu tinha uma reunião muito importante
era uma das regiões mais importantes
realmente que eu teria e caiu justamente
no aniversário da minha filhinha
mas é um adversário no meio da semana
aquele negócio de festa do peão 76 anos
de idade que ela estava fazendo as
crianças vão dar aquela meninada dormir
lá em casa tá dando graças a deus puxa
vida lá fora daquilo que as 15 crianças
dormiam em casa minha esposa coisa de
menina
estou tranqüilo quando ela ficou quando
fui ao papai noel está aqui tá ela
chorar na cabeça e na mão que estava
sendo maldoso não imaginava que eu
precisava estar lá e aqui eu falei não
desculpa filhinha hora depois perguntei
para minha esposa foram até a hora de
cortar o bolo
o papai vai estar aqui eu tinha dois
dias de reuniões extremamente importante
tive que perder o segundo dia da reunião
lá na califórnia
fiz uma conexão maluca na minha vida
agir durante o dia carro esperando
aeroporto de guarulhos e eu eu eu chegar
em casa
[Música]
edson veneno
[Aplausos]
dói
de olho na bomba não nunca perca sua
família nunca teve foi com ele você
nunca são vários lucas nunca esqueça
daqueles que te ajudaram a chegar onde
você chegou
nunca esqueça daqueles que você ama
nunca esqueça daqueles que já que amo
você e principalmente nunca nunca
esqueça da onde você veio muito obrigado
[Aplausos]